there is no doubt Miranda Lambert has
become one of the most influential
female artists in country music for a
breakout single me and Charlie talking
to her fierce country rock hits like
kerosene and little red wagon
her emotional American vulnerability
come to life as she sings about love
cheating and heartbreak and sometimes
drinking all through the different
stages of her life
so with seven albums under her belt
there's no surprise Miranda has given us
some of the top country songs of the
decade let's not forget in 2018 Miranda
won her eighth straight ACM war for
female vocalist of the year passing none
other than Reba McEntire for the most
wins in that category she also made
history that night as the most awarded
artists in ACM history bringing her
total trophy count to 32 for sure
there's many more to come after the
release of her latest album wild card so
in honor of Miranda's birthday were
rounding up her top 10 songs
[Music]
[Applause]
No
[Music]
my brother gather breathing manly so I
thought
[Music]
he can come here
understand
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Hey
you don't know how happy you are
[Music]
didn't give me therefore
[Music]
I can just come and I swear I'll be
we
[Music]
break up
you're crazy
[Applause]
so what do you think did all your
favorites make the less let us know in
the comments below
[Applause]